hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to getting over it with
Bennett 40 I've come down I've relaxed
I've gotten away from the game and oddly
enough when I stopped playing after I
was so angry I actually started playing
again just very casually because this
game is fascinating in that it makes me
exceptionally angry but you can see I'm
back to where I once was it makes me
exceptionally angry but at the same time
not really it's it's understandably like
my fault I know I know I kept
complaining about how the controls were
all borked and all that stuff but it's
it's understandable it's understandably
my fault that doesn't mean it's any less
frustrating but I think like if there's
any lesson to be learned about it is
like that's part of the experience it's
what he's talking about as much as I
still don't believe in the the Phyllis
of all philosophical yeah more slammer
of whatever why well there I go again
well apparently there's a way to get up
there with that which I don't know how
that would be true
I'm just trying it because why not what
if I got better to do with my life than
this huh yep man that that's a doozy of
an order okay let me try to do it then
not that way because I'm a little bit
whoa ah very scary very scary don't do
that ah ah Jesus sure does like to
swings wrong me wherever the hell it
likes to send me as well wherever I end
up wha okay I didn't get the shortcut in
fact it might be better of me just to
like emphasize work on that particular
wha ah there we are
that particular shortcut because I am no
better at getting this particular jump
here than I am at that but you know
we'll see what happens see what happens
okay that's an option
alrighty then
[Music]
alright I'll take it
I'll take it I'll take that to the bank
I'll take that to the bank Wow swing
swung in swings Wong and I don't like
the swings Wong okay back up here now a
Yi how did I do this before I I remember
the way I did way I did it was I shot up
bounced off this wall no why hey how's
it going oh yeah oh yah yah yah yah yah
okay you're just as frustrating I don't
know why but it's only when I decide to
record it that it's frustrating me whoa
whoa why how did you get under that I
have no idea you sack of [ __ ] alright it
ya know close closer to the truth
whoa did I lower my mouth what what's
going on the mouse sensitivity feels
lower than it was before and I I don't
remember
wait that's not the normal weight is
that that's not what that's not what it
was right
that's not what it was right okay whoa
whoa hey there sonny jim you cannot do
that and that would be greatly
appreciated
yeah like that then drop here go up here
whoa like this gentle as the summer moon
gentle as a butter flip okay there we go
go right here nestled in there see the
problem is if you go straight up you'll
bounce but it you got to be a little bit
out ah whoa whoa whoa that was a lot of
sliding
happening and they don't appreciate it
wha-whoa I'm climbing like spider-man
okay here we go
no yes nope nope okay up up nope okay
see I've got better control of it I'm
getting better control anyway whoa whoa
whoa hey I'm in here now okay that's a
weird thing ah oh hey stop being super
oh no that's super wha no no no no no no
god damn it [ __ ] hell god damn it
really god [ __ ] damn it [ __ ] you okay
no I was moving around like a [ __ ]
monkey on LSD but that's not my fault
whoa I'm up no oh come on you dickbag oh
really why why why why I will whoa Oh No
what where am I oh my god Oh with all
this like super movement what a try for
this thing nope no don't get on the
thing oh why I can launch ten bajillion
miles no oh my god oh my god oh my god
that has just the perfect way of [ __ ]
you over no oh God every time it's so
[ __ ] scary every god no oh my god
stop being dick look what oh okay that's
stuck maybe
there we go oh come on
[ __ ] hell why God why why'd you
bounce why did you just bounce I'm not
even talking about the camera balance
this is the proclivity as soon as you
hit - just [ __ ] nudge yourself off
just the slightest bah it's the
slightest [ __ ] thing no no oh my god
Jesus Jesus Christ it's it's like I'm
not doing anything more it's the level
of control yeah [ __ ] damn it again
really again god damn it I'm turning
this sensitivity down Oh
are you [ __ ] kidding me I will burn
my own house down you piece of [ __ ] and
use your cauldron to put it out come on
you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] god dammit god
[ __ ] damn it I was doing beautifully
I was doing wonder [ __ ] Lee oh god damn
it
Jesus Christ what is happening to me
what does happen what's happening to me
oh my god oh my god I made this it's
[ __ ] easy Jesus Christ I did this
already oh my god yeah I'll do it that
way but I I know it oh my god what is
going on with this [ __ ] mouse I and
yes I'm blaming the mouse right now
because the mouse is just being a
[ __ ]
idiot the rules are if the rule if the
rules are so oh my god just [ __ ] go
and now I'm having trouble in the most
basic [ __ ] it doesn't make any goddamn
sense and I'm not it's not like I'm
taking a quit what is going on with my
[ __ ] mouth
do you work still do you [ __ ] work oh
wow it's still [ __ ] works great I
just spilled a [ __ ] drink
god dammit [ __ ] me know why I'm so mad I
don't even know why I don't I really
don't know why I I went into this
episode I was like alright I got this
it's gonna be fine it's gonna be 100%
chill shut up I don't I know you
ie well this is this is an interesting
decision No
why did you just do that please nope god
damn it god [ __ ] damn it
it was not oh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
easy there ah god I was right there how
many times have I been right there
nah come on just cooperate no oh my god
oh my god what what are you doing see
see see it's not me it's not me it's not
me it's not me it's me I know it's on
represent me I know the slightest breeze
that was going straight for death no oh
come on the floor [ __ ] bounce Jesus
Christ I just want to get back to where
I was that's all I want
I don't I don't want anything else for
Christmas I just want to get back to
where I was and I can't get past this
[ __ ] part no every time it's like ten
[ __ ]
Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's so [ __ ] stupid and yes I know
there's speedrunners that can do it in a
couple of minutes and like they make no
mistakes going up and yeah they've
probably been practicing for a long time
but I bet even they could say that the
old God well that was those it's just
the inconsistencies like that's the only
thing that I really don't like well oh
well I kinda kind of a little bit please
it bypassed a lot of [ __ ] let's see
if I can stay up here which I guess I'm
not gonna be able to that's my big
prediction yep there we go that's my big
Buddha thought my big prediction came
true hey there we go whoa wait hang on
no no no no I said there we go there we
go okay Wow I got it apparently I think
I think I know the trick to get up there
now not really it's not really a trick
it's just go launch yourself whoa big
boy big boy with the big attitude whoa
whoa whoa whoa easy easy easy there what
was that
Chism's
Oh
I just learned a fundamental mechanic
about this game this is why it's
inconsistent I had no idea
when you move the mouse it returns
holy [ __ ] you guys don't understand how
groundbreaking this is now I'm not
saying that now that I know about this
I'm gonna be suddenly good but this is
the one thing of inconsistency that I
was not getting when I move the mouse
you see the cursor it returns to the
head of the hammer that's what I was
fighting that's what my hand is trying
to correct
that's why oh because I every time I
land I'm trying to fight that movement
when it automatically returns to the
center and that's why it follows the
camera because if the position of the
head moves that makes so much more sense
now again that's not gonna make
everything suddenly hunky-dory but it oh
whoa it makes sense in my brain that if
I don't want to bounce I just stop
moving the mouse whereas before I was
trauma that makes so much more sense
whoa whoa whoa yeah
hi yeah okay all right after a long
arduous journey I have returned to my
home amongst the castles the the the the
sky ie okay all right somehow I'm back
here all right so you need to go mr.
orange excuse you you could almost reach
it right there so it's not even that
high up but I got a swing out if I swing
in its doom whoop and there we have it
okay all right well that's wonderful
yay I'm not celebrating because I know
that I could screw this ah screw this up
at
any moment okay gotta make a move here
thank you everybody so much for watching
that's all the time I got for getting
over right now I've learned things but
they don't help me they do not help me
nothing can help me nothing can help me
nope nothing can help me let me know
what you think down the comments below
and as always I'll see you in the next
video bye-bye
[Music]